(gun fires)
- Jesus.
(camera operator laughs)
- [Shooting Instructor] Your finger.
- What just happened?
(ambient music)
I'm in Switzerland, and there's
a big festival going on.
(ambient music)
Everyone has the day off.
They're all gathering to have
a good time to celebrate guns.
(gun fires)
It's a shooting competition for teenagers,
and they've been doing
this for hundreds of years.
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Johnny] It used to just be boys,
but now it's boys and girls,
and the winner is deemed the
king or queen of shooting.
- [Interviewer] (speaking
foreign language)
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Interviewer] (speaking
foreign language)
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Interviewer] (speaking
foreign language)
- (speaking foreign language)
(ambient music)
- [Johnny] Switzerland is a
peaceful, neutral country,
and yet it is full of guns.
The government gives its citizens guns
and trains them how to shoot.
Every village is required
to have access to a shooting range.
- We have almost as many guns per head
or per person here as in America.
- Back home in the United States,
we also have a lot of guns,
but the culture around
guns is a little different.
- [Ronald Reagan] The right of the people
to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed.
- The country of Switzerland proves
that there's no need for more gun rules.
- Guns are the number one cause of death
among children in the United States,
yet we don't have the will to stop it.
- Switzerland has the
lowest crime rate in Europe.
- That's all we have at this
point, God and our guns.
- I really want to get to the bottom
of this gun culture thing,
why these two countries
have such vastly different
relationships with guns.
So I delved deeper than I usually delve
and found myself digging
through old literature
from Scottish political philosophers
and looking into the
constitutional archives, talking
to Second Amendment experts, talking
to military historians from Switzerland
and it's finally all clicked for me
and I want to share that with you.
So buckle up for what is
going to be a wild ride
through history and an
adventure through Switzerland.
(ambient music)
So as a side note to this
story, I've been finding a lot
of bunkers in Switzerland,
which if you all remember, a year ago
from right now, I
published a video about all
of the bunkers hiding in Switzerland.
And now that I'm here again,
I find myself stumbling
upon more and more bunkers.
Anyway, I also want to
tell you that my trip here
to Switzerland and my ability to go around
and shoot at shooting ranges
and spend months diving
into Swiss history is made possible
because of our generous sponsors
who come back month after month
to support our journalism.
BetterHelp, who's the sponsor
of today's video is a platform
that is making therapy
more accessible to people.
Normally what you do
when you want a therapist is
you like call around, you see
if like a therapist has availability.
Here in the United States,
you like check to see
if like your insurance
works with that therapist.
You wait a few weeks, you schedule back
and forth over the phone,
and then maybe you see a therapist.
And if they're not a good
fit, like good luck, you have
to do it again.
With BetterHelp, you basically sign up,
you fill out a survey, the
survey then matches you
with somebody in their giant network.
They have a huge network
of like tens of thousands
of like licensed therapists.
They'll connect you with one
that they think is a good fit for you
and you can start communicating
with them right away.
You can talk by phone, you
can talk by video chat,
or you can just do like chatting back
and forth over a text message.
You get to decide that.
If you don't like your therapist,
you can change your therapist.
I went to therapy not
because I had a clinical
diagnosis like depression
or anxiety, but because I'm a human
who has stressful things
in my life and has a lot
of inner voices telling me how
I should think about myself
and some of those voices aren't very nice,
and I wanted to understand my inner self
and understand my mind
and start to retrain it.
That's what therapy is
and it has changed my life in huge ways.
So I'm really grateful
that BetterHelp is making
therapy more accessible
to people via the internet.
There's a link in the
description of this video.
It's betterhelp.com/johnnyharris.
When you click the link,
it tells BetterHelp
that this ad is working and
it supports this channel.
And if you wanna sign up
for BetterHelp, you get
10% off your first month.
So you can try it out at a discount, see
if it works for you and yeah,
you can give therapy a try.
Let's get back to the video.
I'm in beautiful Switzerland,
here, shooting guns
and learning a lot about firearms.
Let's go.
(intense music)
There's the shooting range and
the targets are on this side.
Oh yeah, there's the targets.
(gun fires)
Oh, I hear them. Holy smoke.
So they're literally shooting
over the road right there.
Oh God, those people.
Geez, there are bullets flying
over our head right now.
Oh my God.
That is such a weird feeling.
Headed to a shooting competition right now
at this shooting range surrounded
by beautiful Swiss mountains.
The sound of these guns. My
god, it's like a war zone.
Oh wow.
- [Patrick] But this,
but it's only six rounds.
- [Johnny] Yeah.
- [Patrick] Because it's single loaded
so you always have to,
(gun cocks)
- [Johnny] You always
have to cock it, yeah.
- [Patrick] Then you can
make it wider and smaller.
- Yeah.
- And you can even...
(gun fires)
- As I'm standing here,
you realize like the cars are right there.
You could easily shoot
them if you wanted to,
if you were standing up.
Like I knew that this existed.
I saw the Tom Scott
video a few months ago.
I thought it was like there
was one crazy shooting range
in Switzerland that goes over a road.
I didn't realize it was common.
It's a friendly competition.
It's all very wholesome.
You see these young kids
that are like keeping score,
tabulating all of the results.
I've been hanging out
with the president of one
of these shooting clubs trying
to understand a little bit
better about what this event
and things like this represent
for these communities.
- The military law tells all
the villages that they need
to provide a shooting range
or a possibility to shoot.
- We got the ammo, military
provided at a discount.
- [Patrick] Just try again.
So you're right-handed?
- Yep, I'm right-handed. Is
there a telescope in there?
Like how am I seeing that far down?
- No, there's no telescope.
- There's no telescope.
Oh, that's what makes it.
- You're not allowed to
use any sights, any optics
at any competitions in Switzerland.
- Okay, so you're gonna
make sure I don't hit
any of these cars.
- Yeah. Now you're not able
to see any cars anymore?
- Nope, no more cars.
- [Patrick] Okay, so no more cars.
No more problems about that?
- [Johnny] Yes.
- Maybe, yeah, move a
little bit further, yeah.
You're ready?
- Yeah, I think I'm ready.
(gun cocks)
- Whoa.
- Now it's loaded. It's ready to shoot.
- Oh my God. Okay.
- Target 19.
- Target 19. Here we go.
(gun fires)
- Very slow. Now you
pulled all the way through.
- Oh, I did. Yes.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yes, I forgot about that.
- That's why normally
we train how that works.
But you hit the target.
- I hit the target, that's good. Okay.
- You can actually hit the target.
(gun fires)
That's good.
- Oh, there we go.
- Now we saw it.
- I'm getting better.
As I shot in my first gun
competition, I was surprised
that my instructor kept telling me
to relax, to breathe, to turn inward.
(gun fires)
- Exactly.
- Yeah, that felt way more relaxed.
- [Patrick] Now hit the 10.
- Oh, there we go.
- Here we go.
- Wow. I turned inward,
relaxed, and I hit the 10.
Sharpshooter over here.
Wow. This is addictive.
I definitely see, I'm like,
I could do this all day.
- So this is like relaxing
or calming down for me.
Sometimes I feel like I'm
going into another world.
You turn your focus
from focusing outside,
you're focusing inside.
- Wow. This is fun.
Objectively, this is just fun.
And it's beautiful.
I'm like looking at the Swiss
countryside. It's great.
My experience with guns
as a kid, I would go out into the forest
and like blow up like glass
bottles with shotguns.
- [Patrick] That's what what
I think America is all about.
- Wow, that was awesome. I
kind of wanna shoot again.
I never thought I'd say this.
I'm not a gun person, but I'm like, I kind
of want to like shoot more.
Like, this is so fun.
I was struck by how
peaceful and celebratory
and wholesome this all was.
So much different than
the way guns are presented
in the USA.
So how did we get here?
(ambient music)
The story of Switzerland starts here.
Well, actually down there at that lake
in a little green valley where a group
of people came together and made a promise
to each other 700 years ago.
And with that promise came a myth.
The hero's name was William Tell
and legend has it that one day he refused
to bow down to the king's local leader.
It was a daring act of disrespect.
So as punishment, the overlord forced him
to shoot an apple off his own son's head.
Tell aimed his crossbow
carefully and released.
He made the perfect shot.
He continued to defy the ruler
and eventually inspired the tribes
in this region to launch a rebellion.
Tell eventually shot the ruler dead
and the rebels would go on
to win their independence,
banding together
to start the Confederacy that
would become Switzerland.
They first made an agreement
that they would protect one another,
but instead of forming a
full-time standing army run
by a king, they would arm
and train ordinary people to fight.
So not an army at all,
but rather a militia.
I'm now going into a shooting range
that is in the mountain
in a dugout bunker.
Very Swiss.
(upbeat music)
It feels like the old bunker
days, exploring a bunker
but I am in a shooting range.
Mind-blowingly big.
It's like a maze in the mountain
with just a bunch of rooms shooting.
(upbeat music)
Okay, so now I'm fully loaded.
Safety off. I'm gonna take safety off.
- Yeah, if you are on the target.
If you are on the target
and you wanna shoot, you
can take the safety off.
- Okay.
(gun fires)
Shooting in the bunker is a
completely different experience.
Like you feel the vibration
of your entire body
'cause the echo is so extreme.
I'm getting better at shooting.
(gun clicks)
(gun fires)
Oh my God.
(gun clicks)
(gun fires)
Oh my God. Oh yeah.
(gun clicks)
(gun fires)
- [Shooting Instructor] You
never shot before, right?
- No. Two days ago, I started.
So back to 1600s Europe,
where Switzerland remained
this one peaceful confederacy
protected by its citizen militia.
Meanwhile, in the rest of Europe,
greedy kings were using
their huge standing armies
to conquer one another
while Switzerland stood
by training its citizens
in the ways of war.
Swiss citizens got so good at fighting
that the Pope hired them
as his personal protectors.
Other empires would
even hire Swiss soldiers
to fight their own wars.
But Switzerland itself
remained almost entirely out
of these conflicts on the continent.
Eventually, European thinkers start
to notice this peculiar Alpine
Confederacy, Switzerland,
this place that trains
their citizens to fight
and miraculously showed
that you can have a republic
even in Europe, a sea
of monarchy and kings.
I've been reading a lot
of like old European political literature
and you start to see this phrase pop up
to describe how Switzerland defends itself
using a well-regulated militia.
I saw this term a lot when I was looking
through this old literature.
Around 1610, this British
diplomat goes to Switzerland
and gawks at their well-regulated militia,
how they can overturn their
government at pleasure
because they all know how to fight.
By the way, back in like the 1600s
well-regulated militia
meant like a well-organized
or efficiently run
militia, not like regulated
in the way that we think of it today,
but yeah, the idea was if you
arm everyone in your society
and you train them,
that's actually the key
to the best defense and
the best preservation
of freedom for the
people, not just the king.
This idea of a
well-regulated militia spread
across the ocean to a group
of British intellectuals
who were secretly conspiring
to overthrow their own king.
In 1776, they declared independence
using their own well-regulated militia
to fight off a tyrannical
king and his standing army.
As they fought this war, a
leader from Switzerland wrote
to Benjamin Franklin suggesting
that this new rebel experiment
called the United States
should become Sister
Republics with Switzerland.
The Americans somehow won this war
and got to work designing
their new country.
They sat down in a hot
church looking building
to draft the document
that would be the foundation
of this experiment.
A system free of kings.
The founders studied the political systems
of Greece and Rome.
They studied the British Magna Carta,
Native American confederacies,
European philosophers.
But then there's John
Adams, one of the founders
who was kind of obsessed with
Switzerland at this time.
He studied their system and he was amazed
at how their militia worked,
how they required everyone to
have a gun and to have ammo
and they wouldn't let them
get married unless they did.
He wrote all about this in like a treaties
on different government systems right
before he wrote the Constitution
with his fellow co-founders.
Switzerland was a model.
It was the republic that
had resisted tyranny
and been able to stay free
in a Europe full of kings.
And when it came time to
write the actual constitution,
you can see that a militia was enshrined
in the Constitution itself.
In the Constitution, the
role of the militia is
to protect the government,
to protect the country
from invasion or insurrection.
And then after the Constitution,
it became time to draft
that sacred list of the
most fundamental rights
that would ensure that the
American project remained free
and full of liberty.
The first of these 10 amendments
would be freedom of speech
and of expression, assembly,
religion, and the press.
But right after that, they
write the Second Amendment
and it's about the well-regulated
militia being vital,
being necessary for the
security of a free country.
So to have a militia, the
people must have arms.
They must have a right to have guns.
So now you have the
Constitution, the Bill of Rights,
and the Second Amendment
and then a few years later,
the well-regulated militia
idea got enshrined in law
when one of the first congresses
passed a law that said
that every man doesn't just
have the right to have a gun,
but is required to have a gun and ammo
and must train to use it so
that the president could call
on its armed citizens as
its mechanism for defense.
This whole legal framework
was very clearly like,
yes, you can have guns,
but only if you are ready
to use them to defend our country
from invasion or insurrection.
And sure enough, George Washington
had to actually use this.
There was this rebellion
in Pennsylvania over taxes,
and George Washington
called up his armed citizens
to march and clamp down on these rebels
and it totally worked.
The militia system was
working for this young nation
to ensure its freedoms
with an armed citizenry,
something Switzerland had
been doing for centuries.
Guns started out as a symbol
of collective security,
as collective defense,
armed citizens ready
to stand up to defend the country.
But needless to say,
things kind of changed
when it came to guns in America.
So how we got from that to this
is the next part of this video.
And in my mind, it's the
most interesting version
of this story because it
shows us how Switzerland
and the United States diverged
so severely from this militia culture.
Okay, but before we get to that, I want
to show you more about Switzerland today.
Show you what it looks
like when a country sticks
to an actual militia system
as their primary tool for
national defense. Okay.
(mellow music)
To better understand gun ownership
in Switzerland, I visited
a member of the Swiss Army.
- Hey, how you doing?
- Nice to meet you.
Hey, can I see your gun?
- Of course. That's why you came.
- That's why I'm here.
- You want to play some Where's Waldo?
Where's the assault rifle?
- Oh my gosh, I already see it.
You used to have a gun
in your corner here.
- You wanna carry it?
- Okay.
What's interesting to me is like
for you, this is like no big deal,
for me, this is a giant gun.
Like this is like, I don't handle guns.
Like I held a gun like this
for the first time like two days ago,
for the very first time
in my life.
- No way.
- Yes, actually I'm an American.
- Yeah, that's very uncliche.
- Switzerland still has a militia.
Every able-bodied man in
Switzerland is given a uniform
and a gun and required
to join the military.
- And this is in the constitution.
It's written there that
every male can be forced,
not only forced to do military service,
but also forced to make more.
So instead of 21 weeks, I did 37 weeks
and in total, I have to do like 450 days.
- Up until the nineties,
you would go to jail
if you refused to do this.
Now you just have to pay 3%
of your income if you don't,
- I was also very against the military
and I went reluctantly.
- One of the first things you do
in this initial training is
you come to one of these clubs
and you learn to shoot.
- It was kind of scary actually,
because it's all like
18 to 20-year-old guys
and just like, oh yeah, we're gonna go
to shoot this gun now.
And it's like, here's
ammunition, here's the rounds
and now you do what you learned.
- After the recruits complete
their training, they return
back to their normal jobs,
to their normal lives,
but they keep their firearm
with them in their home.
And then they're required to come to one
of these private clubs every
year to practice shooting.
- (speaking foreign language)
- It's called the obligatories.
So it's obligatory or
mandatory for people to shoot.
- This is my shooting book.
You know, every time I shoot,
there is like a little report,
somebody has to sign it.
Of course when you go shooting,
you just take this out
and then it's just like this.
- Wow.
- And you go to the public
transport just like that.
- You're just walking around
on the train with your guns.
- Yeah.
- Really?
- So it's actually similar to
what the United States National
Defense Strategy looked
in like the 1800s where every
able-bodied man had a gun
and was required to use
it, required to be ready
to defend the country from
invasion or insurrection.
- Part of this is also being able to fight
if it will be necessary just
to, you know, protect our country.
And this, you know,
self-defense thinking is part
of, you know, our people from Switzerland.
- What Switzerland
doesn't have that we have
in the United States
is a Second amendment,
a articulated, unambiguous
right to have guns.
Instead, guns are articulated mostly
as a duty to protect the country.
And then secondly comes
the privilege to use guns,
to compete with them,
to own guns, et cetera.
For them, the duty came first.
- We have a tradition, more
of a liberty tradition,
and there it's more of a
responsibility tradition.
- Essentially, everybody has to go.
So this is kind of like one thing
that unifies a lot of
the male population here.
And it's just like you can meet a guy
and if he is done military
service as well, you can talk
for hours and hours and hours.
- And this to me, makes
all the difference,
like these two different
purposes of guns in society,
whether they are a right for individuals
or the duty of the collective.
I think this is a major factor
that divides these two gun cultures.
If you could describe Swiss
shooting culture in three words,
what would those words be?
- (speaking foreign language)
- And this is where it all clicked for me.
I had thought that Switzerland's
gun culture was the product
of smart laws and gun policies.
But being here, it was becoming clear
that it was the militia system
that was at the root of all of this.
The requirement for every
man to learn how to shoot
as the main strategy for
collective national defense,
turning guns into a symbol
of community and celebration.
The center of large festivals
all over the country,
where Swiss traditions are celebrated
with firearms at the center, like
that teen shooting competition in Zurich,
or this important shooting festival
that takes place at the foot
of the Alps along a beautiful Swiss lake.
The place where the founders
of Switzerland formed
their confederacy in 1291.
- (speaking foreign language)
- You have so many members
of the community coming out
and participating in them.
You're gonna have fun.
The shooting is fun.
They'll have music.
After you're done shooting,
you can have some beer or wine
and it's a family affair
and so they kept that alive.
- (speaking foreign language)
- Okay, we're at yet another gun club,
and once again, this gun club has a target
that goes right over the top of a highway.
I'm here to continue to learn
what the deal is with Swiss gun culture
and to see if I can get a better
score than I did last time.
Okay, so this is the gun
we're shooting today.
Gonna give it a go here.
Oh, there's a kick.
There's a kick on this one.
(gun cocks)
Okay, here it goes.
(gun fires)
- Wow. Geez.
Okay, man, the sound like
echoes through the valley.
(gun fires)
Okay.
Beginner's luck continues. Wow.
(gun fires)
Oh, here comes the score.
My scorecard. Okay, what do we have here?
- (speaking foreign language)
- It's the beginner's
luck. Beginner's luck.
This is my scorecard here.
My moosh, what's it called?
Moosh.
- Moosh.
- I got the moosh.
Yes, so 300 meters away.
I think that this bullet just traveled
across the valley over the cars
and hit a thing that's this
big is pretty satisfying.
So while I'm sitting here
shooting bullseyes right below us,
not only are other cars,
but there's a guy just mowing the lawn.
Like there's a guy mowing
the lawn right there
under the shooting range.
This place is at once super buttoned up
when it comes to guns and
seemingly very relaxed,
but it's not relaxed.
As I visit these gun clubs, it's striking
how much these feel like a magnet
for community, a gathering
place for the community,
a collective activity and competition
that everyone in the community can enjoy.
I'm so used to guns being
associated with danger
and division and politics and fear,
but here it just has such
a different feel than
what I'm used to.
Thank you so much. I really
appreciate your time.
Thank you.
This is really good.
It's been a really enlightening experience
visiting all these shooting ranges.
And what it's taught me is
that guns here in Switzerland
are a totally different
thing than they are in America.
Like they're a completely
different symbol.
They have a very different purpose.
They have a very different meaning.
And that's kind of surprising to me
because remember that the
United States was founded
on a lot of the same
paradigms as Switzerland
when it came to having a militia
and having firearms in society
as a form of collective defense.
So to understand how
these two gun cultures
so greatly diverged despite
having similar roots, you have
to understand what happens
after the Constitution,
after the Second Amendment.
- I have the right to
protect my family and myself.
(gun fires)
- What do you think about
American gun culture?
Like what's the view?
- (beep) bonkers.
The fact that everybody
has a gun in America.
It would make me feel uneasy.
And I'm used to being in the proximity
of guns because I'm allowed a gun.
I don't know how you guys do it.
- And if he tries to take
our guns, he can take them
from our cold, dead hands.
- There has been a
shooting at a synagogue.
- Get off of my porch right now.
- Gun control, all it's
gonna do is take the guns out
of the people that obey the law.
- Three people were killed in
Jacksonville, Florida today
after what appears to be a
racially motivated hate crime.
- [Johnny] So after its
independence, the US quickly learned
that while a militia is
great for defense, deterrence
and neutrality, it is not
good for one thing, conquest.
Beginning in the 19th century,
the US expanded west very quickly.
They fought other European colonists
and Native Americans for their land.
They would eventually fight
each other in a civil war.
These kinds of operations were too big
for militias made up of everyday citizens.
Instead, they needed to establish
and fund a centralized,
professional standing army.
And this was just the beginning.
By the time the 1900s rolled
around, the US had grown
into something that Switzerland never was
and probably never will
be, an expansionist empire
using its sprawling permanent military
to wield influence around the globe.
By the middle of the century,
it would become the largest
and most powerful military
to have ever existed.
Because the US had a huge
standing army, it did away
with a lot of the original
laws requiring people
to join the militia.
And now without a duty to form a militia
to protect the country from invasion
and insurrection like the
Constitution said, they were left
with just the second half
of this amendment, the right
to bear arms and how it
should not be infringed.
Guns started to become more
of a personal tool, a tool
to pursue their American dream, to hunt,
to protect their family, to exterminate.
- It's more like the Rambo style.
It's not like, I'm going
shooting at the target.
You don't go shooting
somewhere in the woods
or in the forest, you just don't do that.
You go to a shooting range and
you get part of the community
and then your goal is not just
to, you know, shoot wherever there is.
So your goal is to get better.
And your goal is not just to shoot around.
- [Johnny] Guns continued to
take on a more personal symbol
in the sixties and seventies when more
and more Americans were losing
trust in their government.
This was also right at the time
when crime was skyrocketing in America.
Without this duty for collective
defense, guns became more
and more a symbol of personal defense
from all of this crime, personal liberty
and a symbol of this growing
anti-government sentiment.
And as a result, the number
of guns in America soared.
The NRA, which remember
after the Civil War started
as a largely non-political
group that was meant
to just help Americans be more responsible
and better marksmen, they got
taken over in the seventies
by a group of hardliners who wanted
to change the agenda of the NRA, turning
into a political lobbying
group that was set
on reshaping the way Americans thought
about the Second Amendment and making sure
that no legislation ever made it through
that curtailed gun rights.
They began pushing an interpretation
of the Second Amendment
that was about individual
protection, a right to bear arms
so that you can protect yourself.
And trying to de-emphasize the connection
to a well-regulated militia as the purpose
for this right to bear arms.
- In the face of this relentless onslaught
of gun control schemes,
you're the reason the Second
Amendment still stands.
You're the tip of the spear.
- You're the ones that make it possible
for us every day to defend this freedom.
- And it totally worked.
The Second Amendment became
more and more a guarantee
that everyone can have
guns to protect themselves
and their family having nothing to do
with protecting the country.
After all, we had the biggest
military in the world.
We didn't need a militia anymore.
- [Announcer] Don't let
Hillary leave you protected
with nothing but a phone.
The NRA Political Victory
Fund is responsible
for the content of this advertising,
- This interpretation of guns
and the Second Amendment would
become solidified in a five
to four vote in the Supreme Court in 2008
when the court ruled
that the Second Amendment
guaranteed people
to have guns, even when those
guns have no relationship
to an armed militia.
So this is why the United
States has more guns
than any country on Earth
because the courts have ruled
that guns are an individual
right, a right to bear arms.
Every year, 20,000
murders occur with a gun.
Thousands of children and
teens are killed with a gun.
Hundreds of deaths are caused
by gun accidents, hundreds
of mass shootings
and of course, the leading
cause of gun violence, suicides.
Tens of thousands of lives taken with guns
but we can't seem to do much about it
because as long as guns
remain an individual right
now deeply woven into
American identity, any effort
to try to pass reasonable laws, to try
to limit these countless
deaths that we have
in our country will
continue to fail especially
as the NRA continues to politicize guns,
to use them to divide
America, to scare America,
and to make us feel like
we need guns to be safe.
- The facts are on our
side. Guns save lives.
- And you'll never stop us
from defending our families.
- [Johnny] My last visit
was an important one
to this gun shop where the owner is Swiss,
but is a card carrying member of the NRA
and a big fan of American Gun Culture.
I had to get his take on this.
- These are the best
assault rifles in the world.
- Really?
- These are, yes.
- Wow. What what makes them so good?
Why are they so good?
- They're Swiss made. (laughs)
Any questions?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly.
You don't need to say anymore.
What do you feel when you
look at American gun culture?
- It's very interesting.
From the gun system,
from the gun laws, I would
like to live in the States
but not with all the dumbasses around.
I don't know why there are
so many deaths, accidents
with firearms and here, nothing.
I don't know why.
Why all the US Citizens so stupid
and let a loaded firearm
there on the table
with kids 1, 2, 3 years old.
I don't know why.
You need some rules.
Our government, they
support shooting clubs.
They do support ammo.
They support shooting ranges.
They support the guys who are
going to a shooting range.
You need rules. You need to have it.
- Yeah.
(ambient music)
So here's my conclusion in all of this.
I went into this story thinking
that I was gonna tell a policy story like
how different policies
would affect gun culture
and it totally took a different route
because I learned sort of halfway through
that guns are a symbol.
They're a symbol. Yes, they're a weapon.
Yes, they're a sports tool,
but they're also a symbol for
the people who wield them.
The way we see guns is deeply influenced
by the stories and the
myths of our societies.
Switzerland and the United
States have two very different
stories and because of
that, they have two very
different gun cultures.
For Switzerland, having armed
citizens who are trained
with weapons is what kept
them neutral and safe
as a group, as a collective.
The United States admired
this and tried to copy it
and they did for a while
but soon the demands of an
expanding empire allowed
that vision to fade and turned the meaning
of guns into something
different, making it a right
for individuals to protect themselves.
Most guns in America are
not used to protect people.
That's not what they're used for.
They're often used at a
shooting range or hunting
or to end someone's life.
And yet to the people who
hold fast to their firearms
as a right, they feel like any change
to that, any legislation to change
or to limit those guns is a
taking away of their right.
So the way I see it, as long
as guns are an individual
right, associated
with personal protection
and personal liberty,
not a lot's gonna change in America.
We certainly don't stand a chance
of having a culture, anything like
what we've seen here in Switzerland.
And that's a shame to me. That's a shame.
(mellow music)
Hey, before you go, I need
to tell you one last thing,
which is that we made
probably our last batch
of the poster that I designed last year.
It's a poster called All Maps Are Wrong
and I'm very proud of it.
It shows all the ways that
you can take our earth
and project it onto a 2D plane,
which always comes with some distortion.
Anyway, it's kind of a
nerdy map lover thing
and if you're into
that, you should go over
and check it out before they're all gone.
This is probably gonna be our last batch,
so get 'em while they last and
the links in the description.